click an extra button and hello everyone
I believe now it is true click an extra
button dreaming to everybody out there
in the world watching our YouTube
channel as I was saying in the chat room
hopefully this is a special at home
edition of the road mm well the Chess
Club is for the moment back on lockdown
so on my opening series chess openings
explains I have been going over the
nitric opening in the Sicilian and so it
you know got me wondering about the
history and the the person it's named
after Miguel Knight work and while I was
looking up Miguel night or if he play I
found out that he played some really
really interesting games so tonight it's
gonna be all about night or for the
person not night or the opening and
we're gonna see how he fared against
some of the world's best over the past
hundred years so neither played a ton of
very famous people including one Robert
James Fisher so that is the game I want
to do start off with today
of course Miguel nighter against good
old-fashioned Bobby Fischer so let's see
what happened now turf started with d4
Fischer plays Knight f6 yes hello hello
everyone we are finally live here
and we have the Kings Indian defense
neither plays efore as is normal d6 and
after Bishop e2 and castles we are in
the quote unquote classical Kings Indian
defense when Haider if he's gonna get
crushed I wouldn't be so sure he's a
pretty strong chess player he was up
there with the world's best at his time
played in a few candidates tournaments
and didn't do so poorly in all of them
but in this case rather than Knight of
three with kind of the main main line of
the classical Kings Indian might have
started with the shishi 5 first and now
we have c5
Fisher so of course in the Kings Indian
positions we have a couple different
plants that black can go for one is
after moves like Knight f3
the most common way to play is e5 and
there's this plan in the Kings Indian
where black plays the move e5 is gonna
bring this Knight out of the way
eventually and push for something like
f5 and f4 to follow sometimes even
bringing this knight to the f4 square
himself and it definitely makes for an
interesting game after Bishop g5 playing
e5 makes a little bit less sense here
just because this Bishop is gonna be
really well placed in the ensuing
complications white could just play d5
and go back into normal territory but do
you think c5 is also gonna be an option
available and after this move Knight d5
is already going to be rather tough for
black in fact I think Knight takes d5
may already be blacks best choice just
giving up this entire exchange so
definitely after Bishop c5 e 5 makes
less sense which is why we see Fischer
go for the 2nd main plant which is
rather than playing Eve 5 Fischer plays
the move c5 now after this of course it
starts to look less like a Kings Indian
defense and more like a typical benoni
style game has been Simon on vacation
unfortunately the Chess Club has shut
down once again so I am coming to you
from the comfort of my own home
hopefully you guys are okay with that
I'm just happy that I'm still able to
bring you guys these weekly classes so
c5 and now after d5 we do have just a
typical benoni position and now that it
is a Bonomi
u6 is a very sensible move for black
challenging the d5 pawn in at least
exchanging this a pawn for either the e
pawn or the C pawn for white so II 6 we
have
Knight f3 age six to challenge this
Bishop a little bit and rather than stay
on this g5 square where it has the
choice of coming back on this diagonal
at any moment and the benefit of pinning
the knight the bishop now has to choose
if it wants to be on this diagonal or if
it wants to continue pinning the knight
in the game
neither of chose Bishop h4 really either
option would have been would have been
fine here for white but network decides
he's going to keep pinning this knight
and the idea behind Bishop age 4 is not
necessarily to just pin this night
forever and ever and ever it's going to
be eventually that this Bishop can drop
back to g3 and it's gonna have a very
nice safe square on g3 to target the d6
pawn this is going to forever be the
problem with the benoni it's that this
d6 pawn does end up a little bit weak
why not Queen d2 to prevents h6 Queen d2
is actually the most common move here
and probably it's exactly for that
reason additionally of course there are
ideas of playing Bishop h6 and honestly
I do think Queen d2 may be a slightly
more accurate move order for for white
here so well spotted ragnarok yeah hello
to Ethan
hello everybody watching live here Adi I
don't want to spoil who won in the game
but of course this is a lecture about
Knight orifice best games so that may be
some hint to you we did have Knight f3
instead though and it's not as if this
line is particularly bad for white or
anything I do think it's just slightly
less accurate to allow this move age 6
probably White's claim is that age 6
isn't really a move that black wanted to
play and so with this pawn on h6 rather
than h7 some of the light squares around
the black King are gonna be slightly
more weak it's going to make ideas of
playing f5 at a later date maybe a
little bit less less comfortable for
black
that being said just a different line
here he takes d5 LC takes d5 is
white chose to recapture generally he
takes d5 doesn't offer whites a huge
advantage especially in situations like
this where the bishop can comfortably
come out to f5 need this upon here to
number one guard the f5 square and
number two keep plans of breaking with E
5 sort of a live later in the game g5
now was Bobby Fischer's choice and this
Bishop does come back to g3 now Fischer
does something rather interesting here
there are definitely a couple different
ways to play in this position but I'd
like to turn it over to you guys at home
take a look here see if you can come up
with a couple candidate moves for black
there are really only two moves that are
gonna be you know quote unquote
the best here really worth considering I
think so what do you guys at home think
about this one David son says a six
ragnaroks is Knight h5 @ h5 any other
ideas besides a six and nine h5 b six
bishop a six that is one way to go about
things by Manny
okay so these are some pretty good ideas
a six is very very thematic for the
Benoni but in this case but I can
actually get a better version of playing
a six play a six here then the movie
before might come and all of a sudden b5
is going to be hard to to attain if you
play the move Knight h5 but this is
actually the most common way of playing
and I do think this is the best way of
playing and there are actually a number
of games that have reached this exact
position Wang you egg played this
against England with White's so Diggler
and had the black pieces here wang hao
against ali reza firoozeh just last year
reached this position and the one and
only christian trilha has actually had
this
with the white pieces against Alex fear
and so this is pretty normal
this is sort of the natural continuation
to h6 and g5 like I said this Bishop is
actually well placed on g3 pressuring
the d6 pawn this is a Benoni yeah so we
started off in a Kings Indian defense
and then sort of transposed into the
Benoni positions thereafter with this
Bishop g5 line so yeah as I was saying
this bishop is quite strong on g3
pressuring d6 so Knight h5 is really
really natural to just get this guy out
of the way and move on with the game now
the other move is the move that Bobby
Fischer chose and I do think it's
slightly worse here Fischer actually
dared to play the move b5 in one go
which is why the move a six is sort of
not going to be the right idea here
because black is going to be able to
just play b5 rather directly now what's
the tactical justification behind this
well if Knight takes b5 this one is very
easy the move Knight takes e4 comes on
the board black regains the pawn in fact
regains a center pawn and will have
absolutely nothing to fear from this
position with the wide open Bishop if
Bishop takes d5 this one is slightly
less obvious but black can actually
still dare to take this e4 pawn when
after Knight takes e4 Queen and five
check is a simple fork Knight c3 doesn't
do enough because if it should take c3
is check and black will at least be
regaining the piece so always be on the
lookout for these opportunities to play
b5 in one go with the black pieces in
the benoni style positions and when I
say be on the lookout I mean with both
colors you have to make sure that's
you're okay with allowing b5 here if you
are going to play sort of in this manner
so b5 fortunately for white taking on b5
is not forced instead now why it does
get to play the very natural move that
neither place in the game which is 90 to
92 creates the threat of capturing this
pawn by defending a4 it also has the
very very very nice side effect of
defending the h5 square thus securing
this bishop here on g3
okay continuing on a6 to defend b5 and
now white castle's rook e8 played in the
game and now I wanted to ask you guys at
home to think a little bit in this
particular position and try and come up
with sort of a plan of action here or
white there are many different plans in
the benoni that white can go for and it
largely depends on how the specifics of
the opening have developed here so in
this case we do have black and getting a
six in p5 generally this is sort of seen
as favorable for black to have these
moves and we also see black with h6 and
g5 included though and taking some
controlled dark squares but weakening
some light squares and we do have black
sitting a little bit underdeveloped
with these Queen side pieces so with all
that in mind try and come up with some
kind of plan here for white decide how
you want to make use of your pieces in
this game what do you guys think so
Mateo has two ideas one is to play at
four and one is to play a three and
these are are pretty different ideas
altogether well I'm very glad to hear
that Gustavo I'm so glad you enjoy the
lectures as I said a special at home
edition of the road to mm tonight
hopefully you guys are on board with
that and as I've said we're going over
the games of the wonderful Miguel night
or f4 push so you guys are sort of along
the the right track here
f4 could be difficult with your e4 pawn
so yeah this is an excellent point so
you guys are mentioning some really
natural benoni ideas here so a lot of
times in the benoni in particular with
these pawns back here let's say we just
continued along normal lines
neide bt7 caste that's ricki 892 let's
say just b6 or something f4 in these
positions is a very very common way of
playing and just sort of normal benoni
positions you play f4 the ideas control
the e5 square you go for e5 you can even
go for f5 breaks in many many cases of
course however that is not the position
we have in our game here in our game
here we have the pawns on h6 in g5
already and that is in fact going to
change our our position slightly it's
gonna change our plan slightly good
evening
soo Bakura how are you doing super
Karissa's sound effects I hope that
doesn't mean there is sound planning
that shouldn't be but I think all as
well what about h4 hit the hook so yeah
Gus is Gustavo is referencing of course
a previous lecture I did regarding hooks
in chess the g5 pawn can be seen as kind
of a hook here but in this case this is
not really going to be our idea f4 is
kind of an idea worth considering here
but the huge downside to playing f4 when
these pawns are already so well placed
on h16 g5 is that if and I'm not saying
that this should be played immediately
if this pawn ever does get captured then
all of a sudden blacks pieces if we give
them a cup of turns are gonna have sort
of this forever home on ebuy this is
more or less the worst case scenario for
white if you play f4 and the F pawn gets
traded off and black gets a strong e5
square force pieces you're sort of never
going to be able to win this game in the
center or on the Kings side the e5
square is just too too critical so this
is why blacks positioning of his pieces
are sort of really really kind of
frightening for white if you do want to
play this F or idea so it's good to keep
this one in reserve there are cases
where opening
fyo is gonna be immediately and
tactically winning so always keep this
f4 idea in mind in this case though I
don't think it's quite right to go for
it sort of directly in the game we'll
see
Knight Orff had a rather different idea
so f-4s idea is to control the e5 square
but narf also realized that he could
potentially play e5 without playing at
four to support it and the idea of
playing e5 directly is a little bit
different than f4 the idea is you're
getting rid of this d6 pawn and giving
yourself a very strong past deep on so
with all that in mind Queen c2 is what
Knight or started with over defending
this pawn in the case of something like
before coming it's good to have this
extra to the Thunder here and then
Fischer played Queen to e7 and now once
again if we can help it we want to keep
this pawn back on f2 we don't really
want to make this trade just yet so the
simple rook a to eat one is neither a
choice just supporting this pawn from
behind and going for the e5 push
directly without this sort of f4 push
now after Knight B to d7 this next move
by white is sort of the the critical
idea as we hear some Symons go by in the
background the next move by white is the
critical idea to aid this 'if I've push
so it's not going to be f4 in this case
f4 is not a terrible move but it is
rather risky opening up this diagonal
and it's not the most favorable trade of
all time giving up the e5 square so this
next idea by white who thinks they have
it
and actually Yaroslav is just so far
ahead of me answering the question
before I even asked it it's the move a4
and the point of course is you want to
sort of overextend these black pawns not
so you can attack them but so they give
up some key squares in this case it's
going to be the C 4 square that is the
key square for white controls so a4 is
the important idea here by night or to
gain control in the center
before was played and this night just
retreats all the way back up to D 195
was Fisher's choice once again this is
the natural conclusion of putting these
pawns in the dark squares it's for E v
control dark square control now rather
than play Knight C for immediately which
I think might even hang this pawn the
very nice move Knight III comes on the
board by white the idea being you get
the worst night into the game then I'm
d2 is already serving an important
purpose controlling the e4 square so you
bring the knight from d1 out to see for
now we have Knight g6 played in the game
taking a more defensive approach rather
than leave this knight on e5 and have
this night be challenged by the white
knights Fischer retreats this night so
that can actually control these squares
rather than occupy them of course the
natural follow-up here is the best move
just bring this night in to c4 and now
Knight f4 was Fisher's idea so once
again it is white to move and this time
it is finally going to be time to just
break through directly of course the
best move here you have to get rid of
this super strong knight on f4 so Bishop
takes up 4 G takes f 4 and then wasting
no time at all neither place this movie
plot and this is just going to be
crushing in this case of course the move
Knight takes d5 would be highly
desirable but Bishop f3 is going to
start to give you some very very awkward
problems here on this night if this
should be 7 look out for just Knight
takes c6 when you can't defend
everything all at the same time for
example rip d8 takes takes
and I'm not even sure here just Knight
c4
I guess you aren't losing the piece
immediately but of course this is just a
dominating position with the knight
coming in d6 and the RIP coming to d1 to
collect okay so not Knight takes d5 but
rather he takes e5 is Fisher's choice
and now how do you want to follow up
this sacrifice with white what's the big
follow up here what do you do
thank you very much Yaroslav with a why
there are two Yaroslav Xin the chat
unbelievable one with a J and one with
Hawaii
I wonder what subtle pronunciation
difference I'm missing there but yeah
thank you very much for the kind words
I'm glad you like this and there's
lectures so d6 and Bishop f3 are in fact
both very very good moves here but I do
like one more than the other in this
case the point of the e5 sacrifice
wasn't to you know sort of crushing
leeuwin material through some sort of
funny tactic like this in this case I
think actually just Queenie one is gonna
be good enough and black has more than
enough pieces for the Queen here the
idea of course was just to improve all
the white pieces Bishop f3 played in the
game was nighters choice and I like this
one a little bit more because it makes
direct threats to this pawn and it is
sort of just the solidifying move that
white needed to hold everything together
now efore is never a threat 94 is coming
on the board quickly the rook has been
opened up this Knight has freedom to go
wherever it wants and this is just sort
of devastating now for black Queen f8
was played by Fisher in the game but
that of course just gives up the e5 pawn
and now after Bishop d7 the light number
2 comes
to the game and it's it's quite close to
game over here once again tactically you
cannot capture this poem because funny
business here wait a second so Bishop
takes would be the better try after
Knight takes Knight takes the move
Knight d7 is believe it or not a trapped
Queen just straight up this Queen has no
squares and if Knight takes d5
well then 97 immediately is also going
to get the job done
devastating stuff for black so night c4
taking away the Queen's last square and
excellent move by night or now rook a to
d8 and the move here that's I think
justifies Bishop f3 being slightly
better than the move d6 is it does allow
a knight or of this option to put this
knight on c6 it's all about making the
most out of this D pawn on the d6 square
it would do a very good job of hampering
the black pieces but on the d5 square it
does a great job of defending the c6
square as well and na dork uses this to
his advantage in order to improve his
pieces even further put this night on to
on to c6 now of course this rook is
attacked so there's no time to take this
pawn rook takes e1 was Fisher's choice
for a taxi one Rick 88 going for some
trades and in this case neither is just
very very happy to leave these rooks on
the board and goes for a wreck d1 and
the path to victory is becoming quite
clear rook c8 was played in the game and
at this point White has such a
dominating position that you can kind of
spend all the time he wants neither
place I move h3 rather mean if I'm being
honest with you 98 was Fisher's try to
try and regain some control here now
Knight 6 to a 5 is challenging this
Bishop rook b8 the Queen comes in to f5
and this is just a dream position 96
Knight takes D 6 was the end of the game
as Fischer is just blundering material
here with 96 to to a tactic this was
sort of the points of Queen at five
Queen takes T six we have negative 7
37 and mean c8 and this is just deadly
so what was the point of me and showing
you this game other than to everybody
applauded how SmartNet orifice well this
is sort of the epitome of Benoni wins
with the white pieces this is sort of
what the ideal benoni win looks like
what do i mean by that well you just
improve your pieces take advantage of
the squares that your opponent gives you
and then you push C 5 and win with a
strong d5 pawn this is sort of the core
of the main main main
benoni plans and night or if executed it
executed it perfectly in in this
particular case so once again it's all
about mobilizing this deep on in these
Pannonia positions and that's exactly
what Neider was able to do and once
again it all starts back here with
coming up with your plan before you
really start moving the pieces around
out of the opening you want to have some
idea of what you are actually playing
for and what you're trying to accomplish
before you start moving moving the
pieces some more in this case neither
understood it was Queen c2 defending
this pawn a four-night c4 and pushing e5
and that's the plan that he came up with
and executed and Fischer it was more or
less how helpless to to stop him here
who actually still plays modern benoni
nowadays among the strong GM's
well Fischer didn't try Fischer tried to
try to play King's India but this Bishop
g5 move is more or less really asking
for the Benoni unless black is trying to
play some move like night a6 here which
I guess is what you would like me more
see nowadays he definitely deserves it I
tend to agree here I tend to agree
but yeah Fisher went c5 which is
actually pretty common and after d5
get into a benoni at what age was Fisher
then uh let me do some math I think this
game was played in 1966 unless I'm
mistaken
let me check really quick here yeah 1966
so do your own math there I don't
remember when Fisher was born but this
was played in 1966 so not too far away
from 1972 when he was winning World
Championships but I guess he was pretty
reasonably young okay of course it
wouldn't be a lecture about miguel night
or if i didn't include a game in the
night or so the game we just looked at
was bobby fischer with the black pieces
against Miguel night or neither of
course is the topic of tonight's lecture
and now this is the game between black
lejos Laos I don't know how to say his
name
Steinar against Miguel night ourf and
this of course is going to be his
signature opening we have the Sicilian
dr. D for takes takes Knight f6 Knight
c3 here a six would bring us into the
main line neither did Bobby lose Bobby
did lose he resigned after 96 I'm glad
you are enjoying it agita I'm glad
you're a fan and here actually neither
did not play a 6 instead choosing a 6
but we very quickly transposed from the
Scheveningen after Bishop g5 and a 6 now
this is well and truly just the Bishop
g5 night or where black goes east 6
after Bishop e5 so we could have arrived
here by the more normal in the border a
6 Bishop e5 e6 this is normally how
these things go but b6 first
in now a six is the network so of course
the most topical line even back in those
days was this move f4 and this is what
was played here today and now there are
various ways for black to approach this
move the idea for white is generally to
push something like f5 and try and
checkmate the black King in these types
of lines and so one of the most popular
variations as super Qura is recommending
is to play Queen b6 and go through the
poisoned pawn where black is capturing
this pawn on the B 2 square and getting
checkmated for it these days I think
this move h6 is sort of a subtlety that
MVL has started including where after
Bishop h4 and 26 we get the same
variation but the bishops on h4 rather
than g5 in this matters for some reason
if you want to know all the civil teas
on that stay tuned for more chess
openings explain of lectures where I'm
going to keep going through the night
orc and I'll tell you all about the
differences here but we didn't see any
of that in today's game in this case
neither played the move Knight B visa
which i think is an OK variation for
black I do know a lot less about this
particular one and then I do about the
poisoned pawn stuff but Bishop c4 was
his opponent's response these days Queen
f3 or Queen e2 is a little bit more
common but we have Bishop c4 here and
the point of this move is sort of saying
you know I'm gonna take your e6 pawn you
better be very very very careful and
Schneider sort of leaned into it here
play the move be fine now it is a rather
complex position where Bishop takes me
six has actually been played before by
some very very strong players including
I believe Knight it and I think Audubon
with the white piece is the Beast and
after Fe 696 Queen 85 things get rather
located it takes f8 rook takes that fate
not King takes F 826 King f7 25 b4e 6
check King g8
easy mission - 7 takes takes takes rook
d8 Queen h3 b takes c3 was enough for a
draw and Knight itch against Neji back
in 2010 but we didn't actually see any
of this today that's just to show you
some crazy stuff can happen after Bishop
takes c6 so if you want to play like
this with the black pieces you pretty
much have to know what you're doing and
this game though the much simpler Bishop
b3 was White's choice sort of shine away
from the bishop takes c6 challenge and
now Knight c5 was played by Knight earth
and looking back this move was probably
just a bit of a mistake white can
actually get a pretty significant
advantage as we'll see in the game best
move here has been played before and
that is just to go Bishop e7 what's the
difference well the difference is you
are much better prepared to meet to move
e5 in this case because your knight has
not gone to c5 so you are just directly
controlling this square after Knight c5
obviously now the best move is going to
be e5 as this night has left the
protection of the e5 pawn if you are a
fan of Maurice Ashley you've probably
heard the term Aikido chess this is a
favorite term of his and that means sort
of gosh I'm my memories failing me on
the exact meaning but it's sort of the
idea that every move has positives in
this case attacking it for attacking the
bishop on b3 but every move also has
drawbacks in this case no longer
defending the e5 square so oftentimes
you'll find that the best move after
your opponent's move is to take
advantage of the drawback that they've
left behind the drawback being this e5
pawn this e5 square is a lot less
directly controlled by the knight on c5
and that's exactly the case here the
best move for white is the move played
in the game in five and now black is in
serious trouble right this is a pin and
this is a pawn attacking the pinned
piece you're going to be in a little bit
of trouble in the game we have D takes
e5 in F takes e5 and now blacks idea was
to go Queen c7
with the point of meeting he takes f6
with the move Queen e5 check
unfortunately while this tactic works
white does just end up in a very very
good position as this line reaches it's
sort of natural conclusion so it takes
f6 Queen e5 check 22 and either Queen
takes g5 or crewman takes d4 earth Queen
takes d4 you're asking for trouble
so Queen takes g5 gets the better move
but now simply castles and white is is
kind of dominating here if Knight takes
b3 in order to give the bishop a square
now you take some III guards the square
and after that remove Bishop e7 to
create threats Knight a5 is highlighting
just how pinned down the black pieces
are and this is going to be rather
difficult for black to survive
fortunately for Knight earth in the game
his opponent sort of believed him and
didn't go in for this Queen 5 in Queen
takes g5 nonsense probably because it
isn't the most natural thing in the
world to give up this Bishop on g5 this
is a very strong attacking piece placed
right here and why just renews the
threat with the move Queen e2
unfortunately though for white now the
defensive move Knight to d7 is enough to
kind of just equalize here with the
black pieces
once again this is Steiner against
Miguel Knight org and believe it or not
the night off now it is a rather
complicated position white could sort of
keep the balance by queenside castling
here and this does just give up this e5
pawn if black chooses to capture it but
of course black is going to have to be
to face these threats on the e-file
gonna have to play a move like f6 and
there's plenty of problems to solve here
with black in the form of developing the
remainder of these pieces black can also
try or I could also try an interesting
move a Bishop d5 the point being if you
play by should be seven white is just
going to capture this piece and now this
now I don't see five is looking a little
bit empty without anis bishop on beat
three take advantage of but probably the
Newberg b8 here and after Queen side
castles this is just gonna be some
horrific mess in the game though we do
actually see not Bishop d5 but ninety
five by whites and the idea that I
didn't mention
if black just captures this is of course
that the move east six is going to be
rather strong for white same idea as
Bishop d5 here
uh yeah Gustavo so of course the down
the drawback tonight c5 is undefended
the e5 square and so the best move in
some cases is going to be to take
advantage of that and that's not always
the best move but it is a perfectly
valid way of trying to play it and yet
turns out this is actually going to be
pretty good for white in this case if
you take this guy we will take that and
if you take this guy again look out you
are getting checkmate it in two so a
pretty nasty stuff in the game
neither plays the best move which is
just to step out of the way and
sometimes this is the the best way to go
when you're facing down these complex
variations like the move Knight d5 a
huge issue that a lot of people have
when they're calculating forcing
variations is they sort of already
assume that captures is going to be
played you know it's a pretty natural
thing to do say okay I play ninety five
my opponent tapes I play you six he
takes I take on these six and then I
went right 96 Queenie six is meeting -
but of course captures are not forced in
chess and when you place a piece on a
square where it's hanging sort of the
risk you run is that even if your
opponent doesn't capture that piece it's
gonna be hanging on the next turn as
well
and if you don't sort of deal with this
threat then perhaps your opponent can
improve his position to the points where
capturing this piece is actually going
to be good so in a sense while Knight d5
gains a tempo on the Queen ninety-five
is actually a loss of tempo for white
what do I mean by that I mean that white
now owes black a move right before white
does other things he's going to have to
eventually move this Knight off of this
square where it's attacked on d5 so I
think that pretty much just makes 95 a
bad move now obviously in some positions
these types of moves are just you know
phenomenal and even winning but those
positions sort of rely on the fact that
the knight uses d5 as a jumping-off
point it uses d5 to get somewhere in
this case this knight on d5 has nowhere
to go right these are not this is not a
jumping-off point for this Knight you
know this Knight has nothing to do from
d5 jumping into these squares so that's
what makes 95 a bad move and I think
that is the most instructive move of
this entire game 95 being a sort of
fatal mistake here for white because it
is in a sense just a loss of tempo okay
with all that in mind White Castle
queenside and now is finally the time
for black to take advantage of this
night sitting here on the d5 square now
does that mean he takes d5 is the best
move in this position or does that mean
something else you tell me a chat room
what do you think you would play here if
you had the black pieces
what would you do here with black would
you rise to the occasion and take this
night now or is there some way to
improve your position before taking on
tv5 so don't just give me one move give
me you know why you're playing these
moves
1200 so ii takes d5 Knight takes b3 then
queen takes is interesting yarrow says a
knight takes b3 so how does Knight takes
b3 help you what are you doing after
night b3 a b3 are you capturing this
Knight then what's the difference what's
the difference
so Montenegro just wants to take the
bishop and then try to castle so I
assume he's developing this Bishop out
and just trying to Castle kingside age
six to take away the strong bishop
so I will tell you guys that you are not
quite on the right track here it would
be great if Queen 65 were perfectly
legal but 90s p3 is legal and then
you're definitely not playing Queen
takes d5 here when the rook on d1 is
controlling this square so after this
now would you capture on d5 or is
something different so super current has
a fantastic line and that is yes now you
can capture on d5 if 83 or 63 and then
Queen d5 is going to be a great move or
black as you guys were suggesting but
9355 the key point now is you've drawn
this night away from its defense of the
e6 square so the move east six really
drops in power now after a 6 as
super-cry mentioned the only move for
black to maintain an advantage and in
fact the only move to not loose is
Knight f6 the point being you cut this
Bishop off and after he takes f7 King
takes f7 it is going to be an extra
piece for black definitely the
complications are not yet over as there
are some issues on the F file for
example ref one Queen h5 threats but an
extra piece is an extra piece here and
black is doing quite well now in the
game no turf actually went for a
different line not taking on b3 but
rather did h6
and this has a very very similar idea
the idea is this improves blacks
position after Bishop h4 to the point
where it you takes d5 is now going to be
a playable move so as I said this is the
danger when you put your knight on d5
even if you calculate accurately that
your opponent taking your knight is
winning for you on the first turn the
issue is if your opponent can just sort
of dodge the threats you're going to
have to be calculating a takes d5 on
every turn and in every potential
position that your opponent can can sort
of achieve after after the capture
so this is why I think why ends up
losing this game what's the difference
with h6 and Bishop age 4 on the board
well now after e6 the move Knight b6
comes on the board and if you takes f7
can takes f7 check and 28 and now now
black is safe let's compare this with
what would have happened with the bishop
on g5 it takes c6 96 he takes f7 intense
f7 we're get 1 check King g8 well here
unfortunately the move rook takes FA
would be winning the idea being I got
one check King g8 queenie is mate
instead of not checkmate and this is
sort of the really really deep idea
behind h6 so if you guys notice this
then you guys are kind of super geniuses
along the level of Knight orc but
personally this idea was not obvious to
me at all
once again the difference being now
after Knight takes takes check here the
move rook takes FA is just a losing move
because Cain takes f8 check g8 check
it's been on longer mate because the
King has a polite square on h7 and oops
I think I just messed everything up is
that the case hopefully it's all back to
normal
ok perfect so this as I said I can't
stress enough but the reason white lost
this game is because if you leave this
night sitting on d5 then your opponent
is going to have so many different
options to get a slightly different
version of taking on d5 and odds are one
of those is going to be just good for
him you know taking this extra piece so
when you play moves like 95 you have to
be ready to justify it in the case of
many many many different choices figure
upon it in this case 9 goes up the peace
Queen e8 was played in the game and then
a very nice move by night or if here
Bishop f5
this bishop on a swear words attacked by
two different pieces but interfering
with the Brooks access to f8 while
hitting the Queen fantastic defensive
move this Queen came back to e5 and now
the bishop tucks itself away back on g6
and this King has never been safer
ninety-six comes on the board black is
now happy to trade up a piece we did see
six cage seven and now the game is sort
of just over Bishop at 294 h4 and this
is just sort of desperation by whites
but black is just up a clean full piece
with no real issues around his King
Ricky it activates this rook the Queen
drops back to h3 we see Queen c8 now
trying to trade Queens g4 desperately
keeping Queens on now Knight a5 is just
trading pieces and threatening checkmate
as well
hi-5 played in the game and now Knight
takes b3 with check would be playable
but Queen b3 defends the mate so just it
should be for c3 now we take they should
be 7 and as I said this is this is all
kind of just dead lost now for white
black activates this final piece and the
game ends pretty quickly thereafter oops
sorry before played in the game they
should play to be takes c3 you take C 3
and Chapman's
and knight or defeats his opponent in
his namesake opening line so hopefully
you guys really enjoy these two games by
Miguel Maia Dorf
I found them to be rather instructive
games the first one the key idea being
being being formulating this plan based
on the subtle differences in the
structure and the key idea in this game
is being able to take advantage of an
opponent's faulty sacrifice not
necessarily by capturing it immediately
but by first ignoring it and then taking
it on your own terms when you've
calculated a line that's an improved
version for
and let this be a cautionary tale for
those Sicilian players with the white
pieces if you want to sacrifice your
pieces you are more than welcome to but
be aware your opponent doesn't always
have to take them right after this when
you're actually going to do another
lecture here on YouTube hopefully I get
it - to start on time add some tech
difficulties on my own here - with the
roach mm but hopefully that all goes
well over on the endgame class it's
gonna be a little bit more of a beginner
focused class so if you're on the newer
end - chess
be sure to check that one out with all
that in mind thank you very much for
joining me tonight on the road to 2000
as always my name is national master
Caleb Denby I've been your driver on
this journey